all right let's go back to the phones
and try our next caller from the eight
six four area code caller from eight six
four can you hear me what's on your mind
today hi yeah basically I had two
precursors to my question well first the
the definition of terrorism when you
google it and dictionary comm is the use
of violence and threats to intimidating
course especially for political purposes
and also we know for a fact that the war
on drugs was specifically started for
political means and they've used
coercion violence and threats for
decades is this somehow not a form of
terrorism in itself yeah you know I've
heard this argued before and I guess
we're you know we can slice and dice the
definition of terrorism a number of
different ways another popular way to
frame this sort of same terrorism
definitional debate is are any military
actions by a country in some way shape
or form terrorism because they often use
violence and are meant to have a sort of
political outcomes or repercussions my
question to you would be this what
difference would it make practically in
other words we know the racist origins
of the war on drugs we know it's
disproportionate racial impact economic
impact on poor people we know about
uneven policing based on poor
neighborhoods and rich neighborhoods and
we know about how the war on drugs as it
exists was sort of a reaction to the
Civil Rights Act of the 1960s
so what would change if we said hey you
know what it is a form of terrorism well
I actually I would like us to adapt what
is going on in Portugal where they have
decriminalized and actually the World
Health Organization is all suggested to
the u.s. to decriminalize as well okay
no I intended that but hold on a second
let's walk through it piece by piece if
we can let's say we agree that the war
on drugs is a form of terrorism what
impact would that have on any of our
policy wellgood helped to push to stop
the war on drugs that that's where I
would I think our goal would be and put
or would it though because has talking
about American foreign policy abroad as
terrorism in some circles changed
American foreign policy abroad no no
yeah so I'm just not sure I mean I think
it's a very interesting academic
question and I'm not to be to be clear
I'm not writing it off as a silly
question right I think it's interesting
when we look at the actual definition of
terrorism it's sometimes easy to forget
how much of what happens domestically or
even that the u.s. is involved in
internationally could arguably fall
under that definition I just am unsure
what it is we just don't call it that
okay all right well interesting
interesting question I would just
encourage you to think about you know if
we want to focus on that we should
really be sure that it will help us get
to a political outcome that we want and
if it won't it might not be the best
best use of our time thanks for the call
really appreciate it very very
interesting topic